good evening I'm Jordan pare I am a
rhetoric and public address major
studying journalism here at Hillsdale
College and I am a junior Avinash leis
is the chairman of the board of the
Calvin Coolidge presidential foundation
and serves as presidential scholar at
King's College a graduate of Yale
College and the winner of the American
Academy in Berlin jpmorgan fellowship
and the Hayek and basquiat prizes miss
Slade chairs the jury for the haic Book
Prize she has served as a member of the
Wall Street Journal's editorial board a
columnist at Bloomberg and the Financial
Times and a senior fellow in political
economy at the Council on Foreign
Relations she is the author of four New
York Times best-selling books including
the Forgotten man a new history of the
Great Depression Coolidge and the greedy
hand why taxes drive Americans crazy
please join me in welcoming a Medicis
[Applause]
good evening can everyone hear me thank
you if you cannot hear me please stop me
I'm so happy to be here and I know
you're curious about the picture you
have any feedback from the other mic
we're okay I don't know if you saw the
recent study from Harvard that people
are talking about it's about housing
it's a state of the nation on housing
the headline reads US housing market
bouncing back bought not for all and the
report thing the report of course then
goes on to recommend that it is time to
build low-cost housing in the United
States it's time to rehouse that's the
verb Everett America and perhaps also
you saw the story that states are now
calling for greater funding of
healthcare from the federal government I
think we've probably heard that before
or perhaps you've heard the Speaker of
the House calling for update of evade
what we used to call welfare for poor
people that sounds familiar too
nothing is new it is just forgotten
everything we contemplate now has been
contemplated before every impulse
politicians have now they've had before
we just don't remember or choose to
remember especially a period just far
enough away for it to be by many
Americans truly forgotten which is the
1960s
[Laughter]
not for us so so it's your Jodi I want
to go back with you I was very glad to
hear Peters remarks and our remarks
overlap and in a reinforcing wonderful
way so today I want to go back with you
and take a look with you at what it is
we've forgotten really what we've
forgotten not only in the Great Society
but before that and now is what happens
as a result of the collective impulse to
do something for people together from us
you recall the name of the Great Society
and you would call what it was the best
and the brightest domestic version right
the single greatest endeavor by our
national government undertaken footnote
in a period of prosperity so even more
dramatic than under President Roosevelt
who thought he was rescuing the economy
this was an economic effort taken during
prosperity with a specific task to end
poverty big goal the name reflects the
scope of the ambition
President Johnson called his plan Great
Society not good Society
he didn't say better than Kennedy
Society he didn't say better than Ickes
aasaiya t highway plus you know he just
said great he liked the word great but
as this conference is showing will show
I think it's a wonderful idea his result
was not great or even good so this is a
cautionary tale about aiming to be able
and especially claiming to be able to
deliver great as you know the Great
Society is usually lauded in terms of
its legislative achievements which is
sort of default by the end of Johnson's
time in office Congress pored through
226 out of 250 legislative projects that
the president proposed right he was
great
action not just housing
medicaid/medicare the important civil
rights legislation and I agree with
Peter that is important new departments
were created I don't know if the younger
people know that like you've heard of
HUD Housing and Urban Development that
was born in the middle of the 60s HUD so
you want to imagine not a stream but a
flood of laws coming upon the country
coming at the country and usually as in
the Legislative discussion this exercise
is evaluated from the tops from what
other political people thought of
Johnson or what Johnson thought of other
political people like that right or what
the Senate thought or what the
Republicans thought so tonight I'd like
to look at the Great Society from the
bottom the very bottom and from one
single sector housing and indeed one sub
sector of that sector public housing
that is to say projects developments by
the government for poor people and
within that sub sector we're gonna
appear from the point of view of one
individual housing project in one city
is there anyone here from st. Louis
please ask a question and add the
Corrections at the end because I'm going
to talk about pruitt-igoe pruitt-igoe is
a microcosm of the experience of the
Great Society for the very people the
Great Society was supposed to help poor
people the experience at this housing
project called pruitt-igoe would be
comic if it weren't tragic and
pruitt-igoe is worth hearing about
because it Ryan reminds us of the risk
of our current projects housing and
otherwise it takes a minute to convey
the spirit of the venture and the
results and I'm very grateful let's say
to President Arne to Tim Casper to Matt
Bell who I'm just getting to know and
for the end to you for the chance to
speak tonight I want to add a thank you
to Marie's degelman my
friend and colleague from Coolidge
projects as well
this pruitt-igoe story actually begins
before the Great Society back in the
1950s in the prequel Great Society okay
the prequel and also with as usual the
best of intentions after World War two
Americans put their faith in economic
growth they would lay out an argument
like this whereas professor Wolfram
right it would go like this
assume growth pause now he planned
da-da-da-da-da assume but it always
started assume growth they believe
growth happened automatically kind of
like good weather right grouse could
rescue the poor maybe with help poor
families might live in tenements crowded
attend to a room in cities these people
should be able to participate in growth
well we believe that to the part that's
that's more controversial was the idea
that all those poor people needed was a
little help from above a great change
from above so there's a choice on how to
get change even great change because
there are different kinds of great right
one way to get greatness in cities is to
free up markets and allow cities to try
to improve themselves including through
growth maybe then there'll be a better
life for the poor maybe through private
enterprise and and at the time this was
all happening this obscure economist
wrote about cities we must not overlook
the fact that the market has on the
whole guided the evolution of cities
more successfully though imperfectly
than other fashions of helping cities
such evolution the evolution of the city
is also greatness the name of that
obscure economist was Fred Hayek
the second way to at least urban
greatness is to solve the city's
problems from atop via the government
and you know that America chose the
second path the government way a student
growth government can spend and the
federal government will help therefore
the city's needed to help the new
downtown's I'm still in the 50s with new
housing especially public housing and
the government the states and the cities
are all gonna get together maybe with
the private sector and you get a bonus
maybe some stimulus right economic
growth right okay so in st. Louis rows
of shabby cast-iron structures housing
messy rundown shops in the downtown area
so st. Louis was one place city fathers
thought and governments thought the
change had to come slum surgery in st.
Louis was how the editors of
architectural forum described what was
going to happen
for starters as st. Louis knows
bulldozers knocked down 40 acres of
riverside structures including not only
tenements but also in the cast-iron
buildings several going concerns
businesses small factories and into the
vacant lots would go commercial
buildings and structures for tourism and
of course the st. Louis Gateway Arch for
example and in other Lots put you know
gone through by different bulldozers
there'd be the baseball stadium and what
used to be the stove for a hotel that's
the Millennium I guess what and the
corporate buildings pet milk building
but also key was affordable housing
public housing housing was so important
it was going to be a very large group
effort the federal government would pay
and the city of st. Louis would raise
and together with private architects
contractors blah blah blah they built
team effort that's a plus but anyway to
pruitt-igoe the record suggests that the
authorities didn't merely just take care
when it came to building this public
housing project they took great care I
have saved this for you
this is one of the original slides of
pruitt-igoe the theory here was the
better the planning the better the
outcome they're more credentialed the
experts the better the planning the
greater the attempt at precision the
better the result this even though
precision or a pretense to precision you
can just hide that you don't know what
you're doing right introduce fall I'm
not in charge of my growth this is still
the 50s and the planets determined there
be thirty to thirty three towers eleven
stories each the biggest public housing
project great in all of the United
States and there were very high hopes
for the architecture with an Ida st.
Louise reputation they chose an
architect named Minoru Yamasaki he's the
star professor of the International
School he planned an international style
complex very modern but he added his own
innovations to improve quality of life
such as wide halls so adults could
stroll leisurely doors or he staggered
the buildings so let me just see if I
can show you that yep wide halls you
could you could play in those halls
staggered buildings there they are this
is the Lego Land of pruitt-igoe so there
would be light from all four exposures
gardens swing sets for the children the
architects and the st. Louie Housing
Authority meticulously reckoned this
project they determined after much
result of depth much demographic study
that a lot of two bedrooms were needed
and not so many three bedrooms they bet
on small apartments they even put in
under sized appliances to squeeze them
in and Yamasaki did what Washington and
st. the st. Louie Housing Authority said
funded by Washington by the way my
father told me not to be not too hard on
mystery
Masaki the architect because mr.
Yamazaki was a nice man anyhow
small apartments high hopes and they
showed up in the names a pruitt-igoe who
was Pruitt Pruitt was a Tuskegee Airman
captain Wendel Oliver Pruitt who had
flown a p-47 Thunderbolt sunk an enemy
destroyer
off the harbor in northern Italy a hero
and the second set of houses the
officials gave the name of a four term
congressman beloved of st. Louis mr.
Igoe
William Leo I go so the war hero was
black pruitt-igoe was white this was a
segregated period so the vision was they
live side by side and the two housing
complexes that was the plan oops the
plan didn't work because right in the
middle was brown v board of education
turned out they would try to have to
integrate the building's okay so that's
one assumption that turned out to be off
in terms of the budget pruitt-igoe
planners had work with equal precision
they knew poor people couldn't pay rent
at least not initially at least not much
rent but the hypothesis was once the
government was finished building for it
I go it would sustain itself how would
that happen well the people would get
jobs and they would begin to earn more
and you could raise the rent right
everything would be balmy in the
out-years of the charts right and that
works on paper but just in case they
made the building really dense so a lot
of people would be paying rent that
might bring in enough revenue so instead
of say two thousand apartments for the
whole area poor Yamasaki had to build
2870 apartments and he had to scrounge
around fine room to put in all those
extra apartments he didn't plan to get
money to save the housing project to
make it feasible and the end he had this
ingenious idea of having the elevators
stopped only every few floors
that's called a skip stop elevator it
existed and then he would have extra
room in the floors where you didn't get
out of the elevator to put one more
apartment right maybe a three-bedroom at
the very beginning of pruitt-igoe 50s
going into the 60s the planners Eames
did seem to be met I mean compared to a
shabby apartment ground-floor with no
heat where mother might sleep by a stove
which is what happened in some of the
stories we hear about pruitt-igoe these
apartments were like paradise especially
if you lived up top on the 11th floor it
was supposed to be and people said it
was and we have every evidence people
thought it was who lived there a poor
man's oasis residents peaked at 91%
that's pretty good in 1957 they traded
slums for paradise and pruitt-igoe was a
national model it was unti V people in
the pruitt-igoe couldn't have TVs I'll
get to that but pruitt-igoe was on TV
but pretty soon there was trouble of
pruitt-igoe the officers from the st.
Louis Housing Authority and the welfare
supervisors a lot of these people had to
be on welfare
they kind of lorded it over the tenants
and later 110 and his name is Jaclyn
Williams were called the attitude of
these supervisors from the government
who came to the building they would be
like this we're giving you money we want
to be able to control you we're giving
you money so we have the right to make
some stipulations about how you live and
the families were sometimes not
permitted a telephone they wouldn't get
a TV they couldn't pick the colors of
the walls that their apartments were
painted with they had to be white and
what if you didn't want a white wall
Jacqueline Williams mother one of the
tenants they didn't have in her family
that she wanted her children to learn
but they didn't have a lot of scrap
paper to do homework on so mrs. Williams
created a kind of blackboard of her own
by painting one wall black and letting
the children draw on it with chalk well
they were afraid then we get in trouble
for that and lose their apartment and
the social worker came and thought about
it and finally she gave the Williams an
exception an exemption because she saw
that it was important for the learning
of the children but that was itself an
exception there was also true trouble
with the budgets and fairly soon it
turned out there was an oversupply of
one and two-bedroom apartments and an
under supply of three and four bedroom
apartments the planners had had it
backwards huh occupancy dropped that
meant there was less revenue for
maintenance so suddenly the area around
the garbage chute wasn't cleaned as
often as it should be and the management
and tension the management's feeling
tension with the tenants and guess what
the children did not swing on the swing
set they preferred to run in the hall
the st. Louie Housing Authority and its
social workers got really cross why
don't you like the things we tell you to
like it was that the families in
pruitt-igoe split up fast and
sociologists came more planners and they
studied the family breakups and
pruitt-igoe and wrote reports well why
did they break it some of the reasons
they broke up you I think you can guess
many families were welfare families it
was public housing for poor people and
in order to get welfare money you had to
have no dad present in your apartment in
the state you would not get your money
and you would lose your apartment if you
violated the rules of what was then aid
for families with dependent children the
social workers there's a film about this
so I can show you the testimony if you
want but the social workers would
actually patrol pruitt-igoe at night
hunting for dads and dads who dared to
sneak in and be with the family would
hide in
the closet they actually did and the
children were told to lie
oh I don't haven't seen my dad I don't
have a dad and of course that's not so
great for the fabric of the family and
the dad's did go somewhere else where
especially to find jobs and the welfare
moms were all alone single family parent
and they couldn't always pay more rent
and the deeper problem underlying the
split families again was a
miscalculation
it was that not only people but truly
jobs were continuing to leave downtown
st. Louis development did not inspire
companies to expand enough companies
wanted to expand in the suburbs where
everything was cheaper where there was
less crime oops the jobs you were
counting on were gone the broadest
original premise on which this leg of
lamb was built that cities always grow
just was flat wrong so now we have enter
Lyndon Johnson and his Great Society not
so far from here at the University of
Michigan in 1964 Johnson delivered a
famous commencement address he promised
a great society in our cities in our
countryside in our classroom the three
C's he said our society will never be
great until our cities are great and he
declared war on poverty he promised to
spend more than other presidents and
spent note it well because this is the
first act of forgetting with Great
Society one let's call it that
Johnson forgot the evidence that was
already there in places like pruitt-igoe
okay so a Great Society your pruitt-igoe
its 1964 well we we who die go fit into
at least two of these categories cities
and classroom that means they're gonna
get money right and many of the dozens
of new laws of the Great Society
Johnson's program include benefits that
would theoretically applied to us there
was a new law the manpower Act of 1965
to train us improve
I go and Washington of course also
tinkered with welfare expanding it the
centerpiece of the early war on poverty
and and Peter talked a little bit about
this was the Economic Opportunity Act of
1964 that created an office of Economic
Opportunity to help employ and improve
the housing and the jobs employ the poor
that worked by said what what did they
do though that's where the trouble comes
they worked they sent occupations
specialists to help men and women and
pruitt-igoe trained for good jobs and
they definitely trained the men but then
the jobs weren't there oh so you spend a
lot of time training up for something
that you don't get Washington also gave
money to local activists and social
workers to teach the tenets of
pruitt-igoe how to be better citizens to
participate in democracy that's what
started at Port Huron that's what Peter
spoke about you should if you have poor
living conditions in your apartment well
you should protest right Washington also
spent sense of rent money what Nancy
Pelosi would call crumbs money here and
there but the people didn't even improve
would I go which is very important
didn't like receiving crumbs
how far is President Johnson going and
playing the role of Big Brother one
mother wrote in the paper and meanwhile
the garbage kept piling up and the stink
spread and the pipes froze and they bust
and the busts weren't fixed and the
elevators that stopped only every few
floors became cages traps for crime how
that work well people had to get off the
elevator and go up and down the
stairwell to get to their apartment and
the elevator was slow so if they didn't
jump you in the elevator they would get
you in the stairwell they knew you were
coming like it like a salmon or
something they knew traffic was coming
and those wide hallways that were
supposed to be so pleasant right this
sort of quasi outdoor hallways they were
that just enough room for a gang to
stand there and wait for you right and
people referred to getting to their
doors running the gantlet because the
gangs would hassle you especially if you
were boy going to the door so an
elevator plan to make the whole project
feasible had rendered it infeasible
eventually the tenants unhappy with all
this stood up for themselves as they had
been encouraged to do by social
activists funded by the government and
mounted rent strikes and put their rent
money in escrow and who can blame them
but the rent strikes did not improve the
living conditions because the st. Louis
Housing Authority and this is where we
get into the nitty bitty of though with
it bureaucracy wanted to spend on more I
want to spend more on maintenance itself
but it didn't get the money Washington
didn't send that money it was too busy
with other ways to make society great
right so the housing officials in st.
Louis were dependent on the officials in
Washington who were dependent on the
congressmen who were either a reluctant
to spend more or be distracted by
Vietnam right didn't have time for this
and so the money didn't come and the
district pair became great and people
moved out of some of the buildings and
they were boarded out every year
occupancy dropped and dropped again and
the arithmetic of revenue became tougher
this is this kind of story played it out
played itself out of course all across
the nation sending money to community
activists didn't turn out to be a good
idea all the activists did was pester
City Hall you know there were riots 65
Watts Los Angeles Detroit 67 it turned
out that trying to help people didn't
make them any less angry when I'm
writing a book about this period now and
the only people who make sense to me
that I'm coming across among the
protesters are actually the black
nationalists because they said in their
way let us do this on our own
don't butt in any
more I don't need to be taught how to
participate I need to be let alone and
supported and what I do so these results
great society one weren't heated Johnson
forgot his own record or I guess one can
say intentionally overlooked political
forgetting instead of pulling back the
Johnson administration we doubled on the
planning and launched Great Society to
in 1966 and people at pruitt-igoe began
to hear about Medicare and Medicaid that
was Great Society too and more checks
we're gonna come to then into the
dilapidated graffiti mailboxes that were
vandalized but the money wasn't quite
enough to make up for the job loss they
heard about something called model
cities which was very big in Detroit but
here their model City was failing and I
heard about this new department HUD
Department of Housing and Urban
Development and it was gonna send seven
million dollars for pruitt-igoe and
there was some prepare repair there was
some repair and there was some change
for example people got to choose what
color they would paint their wall with
the new paint the new planners had a
whole raft of little proposals like that
and they were very confident because
they were smart enough they could make
pruitt-igoe right this time another time
oh and an example was the issue of
vandalism of lighting fixtures which had
become a big problem lights inside
lampposts outside they were all knocked
out the planners thought this time they
knew the answer which was to design with
expensive engineers unbreakable fixtures
they lodged little light bulbs in little
screen cages so the kids couldn't get
through them wire mesh to break the
light bulb kids and gangs took this kind
of as a challenge and they
they squirt in water through the mesh on
the light bulb until it burned the and
the planner says let's do outside they
developed these globes bulb you know to
house a bulb outside on a lamppost that
were of a new butyrate which was
supposed to resist anything even the
rocks you through it and that worked for
a while
soon enough through the late 60s
pruitt-igoe was so embarrassing to the
country that the first secretary of HUD
Robert Weaver didn't even want to take
ownership of the project Weaver told the
press the pruitt-igoe was a project he
had inherited not his problem and that
by the way it would never be a happy
project he doomed it even the architect
yamasaki wanted out disassociate me
please by now he was working on another
project the World Trade Center Twin
Towers and about pruitt-igoe yamasaki
couldn't he couldn't restrain his regret
he said it's a job I wish I hadn't done
and the key premise growth well we're
still that's still failing to
materialize I mean just to give you an
overview in 1960 st. Louis had 36
percent of the jobs in the state by 1970
it only had 25 percent the city's
shrinking manufacturing where the
citizens that pruitt-igoe would
necessarily work most of them there had
been 200,000 jobs after the war and
there would be less than a hundred
thousand by the end of the 70s so the
ultimate metrics had been way off it
would be nice to report at this point
that Richard Nixon when he took office
in 1969 did not forget as Johnson had
but Nixon forgot to he disregarded the
record and he launched effectively Great
Society three Nixon had his own welfare
program you'll study that in class he
was going to reform housing he got his
own housing secretary was clever and
different that was a man named George
Romney Romney was very self-important
and pretty bright you could see that
very self-important though and Romney
had had he was known as a can-do man and
while in the private sector he had fixed
American Motors car the Rambler so that
it sold that or he rationalizes somehow
and he had understood the market and he
was widely regarded as a genius having
accomplished this with just a few clever
steps he had his own blueprints for a
pruitt-igoe he was gonna tinker now the
way people at secret in the past this
Romney now we're in the early 70s and
pruitt-igoe is an urban ruin this was
his Legoland now Romney's right and so
he works scientifically and he decided
his conclusion was the buildings were
too big right the buildings were too big
people nowadays like smaller buildings
he'd read that in the architecture
journals right they like lower buildings
low-rise what they like now our
buildings or something like that
right then the low-rise was very
fashionable so he ordered two wrecking
companies to do some things from one
wrecking company was gonna split a
building knock down half vertically
[Laughter]
another wrecking company would knock off
the top of a building seven storeys
leaving four storeys ideal urban
planning ideal for stories right
and voila the problem would be solved so
he selected a team for his dynamiting
book too but one was known nationally
for its ability to dynamite with
precision
it's called controlled demolition it
still exists and they said about
controlled demolition that it could drop
a building without even rattling a
teacup it was so good so controlled
demolition decide it was gonna try the
top lopping off that's what it was gonna
do with a pilot on a fallon street to
describe his goal the young man who did
it from controlled demolition he was the
heir to the company name mark was oh he
used a metaphor that had informed
discussion of pruitt-igoe from the very
beginning he said we like to think we
have a skill something like a surgeon
we're gonna fix this building and he's
team planted the explosives in the wall
way up high and they strung the wires
and with the audience of hundreds oh and
including schoolchildren who lived in
these buildings controlled demolition
blew the top off to 207 FL another
company tried splitting but when they
they studied the result they they
weren't sure the experiment had worked
the apartments at the bottom weren't
really habitable there was more mess
than a tea cup broken right under the
console the Romney consults and they
decide they they have to do total
demolition least of an individual a few
buildings and eventually they blew a
number of buildings to smithereens
and you know what it was a miracle the
building's really did fall down like the
experts said they would so at long last
pruitt-igoe had a success for the
planners to claim so would you have a
government that failed at every effort
but demolition congratulations and I
almost forgot in the area of the rubble
there was a new problem that resulted
rats rats rodents so frustrated the
authorities dropped their sights even
lower now they're they're planning
involved rodents the authorities would
you sure the demolished buildings did
not become a harbor furet they promised
st. Louis and that was now all that was
left that the Great Society could
deliver a society with rubble and no
rats another day we can talk about the
general economic consequences of the
planning and all the great societies one
two three four right
the unemployment rose well above five
spending broke the government it turns
out you couldn't assume growth and I'm
gonna use a metric I normally wouldn't
use but I know you've noticed the stock
market's been going up recently and
maybe you think well it might go up just
like that and everyone tells you if you
invest in the stock market well it's
gonna go up you know over time in 1966
in the middle of all this the Dow Jones
Industrial Average which was the metric
of the period hit nine ninety five that
means it was very close to a thousand
and people thought next year it'll go to
a thousand know as the grown-ups in the
audience no forgive me the Dow didn't
definitively across two thousand a
couple times it didn't stay there
didn't definitively cost across a
thousand for good until 1982 that is the
Dow traded side
were down for a decade and a half and
these numbers ladies and gentlemen are
before inflation so what was the essence
of the failure of the Great Society it
was not that the people were bad this is
a story that has heroes and some of them
lived in pruitt-igoe and some studied it
one is Joyce Ladner a young sociologist
who did graduate work there she noticed
something the social workers always
suggested that the residents were
immoral but the social workers had it
wrong poverty never created immorality
poverty created want which is it which
is different the errors were the
planners errors assuming a city will
always grow cities don't always grow
people will always live with forced
integration or school busing applied
from above they won't even if they're
not racist they don't like do from above
the third error was to assume that
cities have to be planned that they
can't evolve ignoring Fred Hayek the
fourth heir was to assume infrastructure
spending always pays back it doesn't a
fifth era was too soon well welfare must
always be good in the case of the AFDC
it eroded families six there the least
observe was to assume that multiple
jurisdictions in a team can work
together better than one Authority wrong
there was sort of jurisdictional lacunae
in this story nobody everybody was in
charge so nobody was in charge as the
business people in the room know synergy
is an overrated concept I see myself
much damage to property rights in the
story the ignoring of the individual a
thought experiment would be the
following supposing we had never created
the Department of Housing and Urban
Development instead we had created the
Department of property rights
to see to see to it insofar as the
federal government may do so that
property rights as regulated by states
are respected then the people of
pruitt-igoe might have owned their
apartments right away and there is
evidence that those who came close to
owning where they had more say in
running the apartment had nicer
structures kept there so that's a huge
error to me but the greatest error the
overarching error like the Gateway Arch
was the sheer arrogance the unrelenting
arrogance of people who thought they
could tell other people how to live
there were observers at the time who
knew this too
the st. Louis Fed is very interesting
and I've been studying it Darrell
Francis who was the the president at the
time they invited all sorts of friends
to talk to them about what was happening
in st. Louis in Washington and one of
the people they invited was Friedrich
von Hayek who was working on what he
called the knowledge problem and just a
couple of years after pruitt-igoe was
blown to smithereens Hayek was awarded
the Nobel Prize for describing the
fallacy of assuming you can know
everything one person you can't and you
know who else didn't forget besides
Hayek Ronald Reagan I would say because
he came into government with a new
approach so now in 2008 we are at a
point when all the great societies have
faded in our memory and our country as a
whole forgets again our own task but I
do in my work at the Coolidge foundation
and what Hillsdale does in its work is
to show America the past models to
remind it of its own past models to try
to help America unforgettable on wreck
lecture about every stage of the Great
Society but you can do one thing you can
tell what happened through stories and I
think you can
at all by telling this single story the
story of pruitt-igoe thank you
thank you mrs. slicks leis we now have
time for a few questions please wait
raise your hand and wait and the
microphone will be brought to you hello
thank you for coming here and speaking
at Hillsdale College um the one question
I had was some heroes were born out of
this could you in I don't believe you
mentioned who those were could you
please mention who they were I think his
name is Sylvester Brown there's a movie
about pruitt-igoe and it's not written
by friedrich hayek it's by the people of
st. Louis so it just tells the story
from their point of view but they they
were leaders for example in the rent
strikes in a good way they were saying
this isn't right maybe they didn't
always have the right solution our
solution but maybe there was some wisdom
somewhere in their solution and if you
watch the footage a pruitt-igoe from 65
to 75 they became leaders in their
community because they stood up for
pointing out the errors I like very much
the sociologist Joyce Ladner who was
only 21 when she studied the families of
pruitt-igoe for the social scientists in
the room she worked for Lee rainwater
who was doing a study and who also he
worked with he worked in the group that
included daniel patrick moynihan and
edward Banfield and a bunch of other
social scientists who were realizing
that the arrogance was a problem as they
conveyed all this so I look less for
civil heroes in st. Louis and more maybe
to people also like Peter here Peter
Collier who came out of what they did
realizing something hadn't been right
and had the guts to speak up about it
michl ice thank you so much for your
time today given your presentation could
you tell us what Ben what should be Ben
Carson's secretary Carson's top three
priorities as Secretary of the HUD today
2018 thank you I had the honor of
visiting secretary Carson the first
order of business is to blow up the HUD
building I don't I don't say that easily
but it is it's in the brutalist style of
architecture by Marcel Breuer it's in my
book and it's it's a double metaphor
because it's very much out of
architectural fashion
Breuer was much more much tougher
architect than Minoru Yamasaki and it it
isolates the people who work there it's
so big it's all concrete right it's ten
storeys a basement above ground they
said but that's what they say and I
think I don't want to in tune dr. Carson
is too precious to be entombed in HUD so
that's one and the number two thing is
they should lead with privatization if
HUD continues to exist at all they
should leave with privatization that's
sort of in his way with jack kemp in
that office at one point was trying to
do but usually HUD the very institutions
intimidates the person who sits in the
chair of secretary and that's a problem
so maybe the institutions this
departments so big shouldn't exist
once again welcome back to Hillsdale a
quick question about the history here
pruitt-igoe was designed in 1950 built
and in place by 1954 HUD was set up in
1965
so it's suggests to me that the problem
that Hugh and I go put in place was more
systemic in American culture and I'd
like you to reflect upon what things
were in place in the Great Society not
the Great Society before it in the great
generation even back to the Forgotten
man or the Coolidge era that put in
place a world that thought they could
invent this kind of thing well before
the Great Society was invented oh thank
you for asking that yeah when you're
supposed to write a history of the Great
Society that's what Harper Collins said
you're trapped but of course this is
following periods we've all studied
before so you start with a progressive
era progressivism started in the States
the state governments would undertake
progressive projects and then that
spread to the federal government under
Woodrow Wilson you know they shut down
the stock market nationalize the
railroad during World War one and you
have scholars here who who teach very
beautifully about this and then there
was a pause that's called Calvin
Coolidge maybe with a little Warren
Harding I hear Warren Harding's up for a
revision and then Franklin Roosevelt
took up the progressive drive again with
the New Deal so the Great Society of the
30s was the New Deal but they at least
had the excuse of economic trouble not
you know so and then you you have World
War two and men came out of World War
two believing it wasn't so bad what the
government did even if it did disruptive
things move villages mow down houses and
so on because that's that's war so you
have a higher level of tolerance that
war it's better than war it that's the
whole story in Europe - it's better than
the war the Soviet republic right so and
they were quite you know they liked
Eisenhower's can-do attitude and he saw
we needed highways and that was an awful
lot of eminent domain and the one thing
that I want to mention leading up to the
60s oh this impulse is always there
growing ever stronger in the United
States I Berman V Parker you know what
I'm talking about they the idea that the
government can take land takings I know
you study at eminent domain it got
expanded it started out it could take
land for a highway or for a government
building and then it could take blighted
land and then it could take in this case
Berman V Parker land that houses that
were next to blighted places this was a
case that was actually about the
property area where HUD is because HUD
the monstrosity would not be there but
for eminent domain they they wiped out
that entire southwest neighborhood in
Washington in the name of the government
and a better society and the center
there is William O Douglas if you want
to get into the jurisprudence so so yes
that's the whole background and it keeps
going on because politicians like the
idea of doing something in it it plays
well with voters
you've talked to us about Johnson and
the Great Society but I know you your
heart is with Coolidge so would you give
us an idea of how Coolidge and Johnson
compared to each other that's a tough
question but thank you for it they both
were vice presidents who inherited the
presidency when their president died
tragically and they do have a second
similarity they both vowed to execute
what their president had promised so
Coolidge Harding was his president and
Harding Manav get the marginal tax rate
down to 25% but he died before he could
and Coolidge gosh darn it he got the
marginal tax rate down to 25% and he
kept the budget balance Johnson very
famously and nobly took it as his task
to continue what Kennedy did
unfortunately in my judgment he went
much further than Kennedy he out Kennedy
Kennedy so that that's the big
difference and Johnson was an extrovert
and Coolidge was an introvert so they're
they're the opposites and Coolidge
believed in Coolidge said men do not
make laws they do but discover them and
he told his father was a lawmaker in
Vermont in the state capitol in
Montpelier sort of there Madison it's
better to kill a bad law than sign a
good one
[Applause]
Thank You Mitch leis it's apparent to
some of us more today perhaps that all
this feigned concern for the poor and
the downtrodden is really just a cover
for an incredible amount of corruption
in which people are liberals in
particular paying off each other and so
will your book talk about that and can
you talk a little bit about that today
is there some evidence of what we see
today in liberalism and government
programs they get they do get the crumbs
the poor are in the rest but Daniel
Patrick Moynihan said I think he said
horses and sparrows the the big eaters
are the other companies that get the
money from the government to do the
project and the sparrows are the people
who get the crumbs at the bottom for
whom the project was ostensibly designed
right what it was interesting to me and
is interesting in researching the Great
Society book is what a role the United
autoworkers played the UAW here in this
state and then nationally led by Walter
Reuther and so there would be a deal who
would build the building for the
government that had invoked eminent
domain right how much would the Union
want an hour to build the HUD building
the workers at HUD when they were
building it went on strike even though
they were paid more than the autoworkers
of michigan president johnson complained
on the phone about it personally the
bulldozer operators were too expensive
there's some tension there
why should public service Bo be paid
extravagantly what was seemed
extravagant at the time and what's
interesting I'll just say about ruther
particularly a lot of the unions were
very corrupt of course huge it was more
institution that what Institute they
were institutions it wasn't about
helping the poor at all it was about
advancing existing Institute's
but the I will say a footnote about
Reuther I he's a sort of misguided hero
in my book the head of the UAW because
he meant so well and he was not
inconsistent he was hard well you know
he really wanted to strengthen the UAW
by bringing the students of Port Huron
in and he subsidized the students of
Port Huron when they met in Port Huron
they met in a place owned by the Union
provided by mrs. Jeffery you know so and
then he supported now did you know that
now the women's organization sent out
mailers its first mailers some of them
came from solidarity house of the UAW in
Detroit because I don't know nobody
looked when you use the franking machine
or something but but he so he he meant
well and he wasn't that corruptible he
gate he wasn't a communist he he but he
was tragically wrong so I am studying
him very hard because he's a character
yes of course there's always corruption
you made the remark several times or at
least one time very emphatically that
the people who had the money felt that
they had control over the people who
were receiving the money I had a very
good friend who not only lived near the
Detroit riots she lived in the Detroit
riots and I'm wondering how much of that
mentality or the interaction contributed
not only to the Detroit riots but also
to watts
well of course it did when so many
promises use something and it doesn't
materialize prosperity and now you have
television so you can see prosperity
which people couldn't before so much
right every night you become frustrated
that's not the only factor in the riots
of Detroit or watts but it's a factor
that someone promises you you are
entitled to something and then Pross you
are entitled to prosperity well I term
prosperity a television set that's what
I term it right looting what happened in
Detroit what were the people arrested
for in Detroit I know you study this
looting the looting they busted the
window of the store and took the
television or the washing machine well
if so I see a connection what I'm
interested in finding is how much for
example and I don't know the answer the
office the OEO office the government
office in Washington funded people if
they did who then might be involved in
riots it's not you know worth a whole
book but it's kind of worth knowing what
part of that this of participatory
democracy turned into riots and was it
at all funded
what happened to the people that lived
in true of Aiko who were ousted they
just get more public housing this I
continued and what happened you know
what I I don't know name my name yet but
I know that someone to other public
housing right so that's a good question
the mm how's holds didn't leave it once
by the time they blew up for it I go
most of the people were already gone
because most of the jobs is that correct
st. Louis yeah yeah where there were but
but maybe we can learn more thank you
very much
[Applause]